boa tarde eu chamo de ensino márcia
silva
sou uma tempo é victor e vou organizar o
próximo internet estimula e quando
manoel me convidou para apresentar o
telex gol em três minutos
é então bom enfim eu agradeço a
oportunidade mas então completamente
primeiro é e com várias questões
primeira que não tem tudo isso canção
pataky história e vida é essa onda
porque obrigou pesar o que vai ser o
tecos lua e poder explicar em três
minutos e ele espera continua a obrigar
a pensar sobre o que é que eu decidi
fazer um telex é quanto a primeira
bom enfim já tô aqui olha mamãe
vamos ganhar está 2ª cipm
eu tenho aqui umas ajudas que esteve
social e vou tentar fazer os hibbing
enquanto a terceira jovem é mais
complicada porque consegui fazer um
lexus boa e é obrigado é 7 sobre comecei
a pensar sobre o que é o tempo e
finalmente o nome dos tempos modernos
vocês viram neste mês acusados
os dados deste ano o tempo acabou na
semana até 2010
duas mil pessoas e ambientes estão
dispostas no mínimo vai pegar seis mil
euros sejam seis mil euros 3 mil dotz
para poder ouvir em directo talks de
qualquer das formas brevemente vão estar
disponíveis na net
mesmo assim sabendo que o mesmo seria
mesmo pagando esse montante
as pessoas sabem a priori que tem que
apresentar um currículo e tem que passar
por um processo de seleção para assistir
depois desde já uma nesta parte
foi dolorido uma série neste menção 2000
tradutores que o dia tem 2.300 em todo o
mundo
voluntários que vão ter um bom esforço
pelos jantares os toques do tempo porque
é que isto acontece
nós temos neste momento já estão online
4800 essas transações são 3.000
tradições em processo de expansão tão
presente em 70 línguas diferentes
é um fenômeno né depois ainda temos
também os físicas como manoel diz vem
tudo gratuitamente
tem um esforço mão um banho e um esforço
considerável na preparação de
apresentações é que na partilha de
ideias
muitas vezes é que o resultado de anos
de investigação de esforço dedicação e
que ele em o de manaus como acho que foi
um miguel veríssimo que vai me ver em
manaus estão a partilhar coisas
facilmente por isso uma patente né e eu
luto mas nada que assuste punha em isso
em pensar nestas nestas coisas todas
realmente em termos de resposta é sim o
terra não é uma conferência na
tradicional
desde a primeira vez que fui a um tempo
em 2008
sem conseguir não foi arno em si o
melhor jovem órfã e ainda escrita para
2011 do que assistir não sei se vou ser
bem sucedida é assistir em junho em
oxford um grito que gerir tudo não sei
se vocês temos tudo tentar assistir
é mas a verdade é que não não dá nem foi
a vinho porque eu sempre ficou com o
mesmo espírito com o mesmo é mesmo
grande expectativa participe sempre com
sentido no momento que realmente me
encanta e regressem sempre com uma
energia imaginava poder ajudar é
contribuir para a divulgação das idéias
confessional e isso é um fenômeno tempo
é e são esses momentos que nos fazem é
vibrar tanto talento não é uma
conferência tradicional é hétero total
rápida já então pra mim é muito mais
para além do tempo nós estamos é uma
conversa que se produz muito mais para
além do tempo nós estamos aqui nesta
sala e hidrantes tia e e santos ou mesmo
para partilhar ideias e podia contribuir
para é melhorar como o manoel lixo volks
correr aqui os meus avós meus as
mulheres como zito porque o que é que eu
ea e chávez ao dizer que era é claro é
realmente essa este curso que eu fiz no
inter por tudo isto eu em 2008 me
envolvi nuno partir daí organizar um
partir daí foi a concretização dos anjos
de uma vencedora do teto 2006 é e foi
por isso também que entende a fazer tv
neste caso o atlético vai conseguir 15
maio de 2010 que chegou há uma semana o
tema do tempo 2010 foi o atuam no idg
now
eu diria que precisamos de menos abertas
e e esse vai ser o tema do t rex boa um
dia de idéias comenta abertas e portanto
esperamos por vós texas rua ponto como
as inscrições
abertas e estão descansados consultar
aqui em cima de um calote já está mas
não subiu tanto festival junto à brigada
ó aqui é vista é magnífica othoniel por
que razão é que o terreno está azul é só
descer logo no primeiro ponto
eu há alguns anos que via o tempo em
dança bom tempo no local e linha e
alguma forma é o entre si e em fio e
orgulho que é uma coisa e raramente uma
pessoa pode ter um site com o qual
mantém ligação obscenamente nenhuma de o
mostrar como se estivesse a falar alguma
coisa que realmente fria logo a mesma
apesar de ser mãe resolveu conhecer e
branco
é claro que uma situação destas eu
gostaria imenso estar aqui é uma
celebração achou da condição mas não foi
desde o início e na região e vavá de um
conjunto só acho que está em trabalhar
hoje em dia vivemos muitos anos vai
dizendo coisas muito rápidas ea um
investimento muito grande humano que
possa atingir a perfeição em seu
especial está quem há vários estudos
nessa área disse basicamente que nós
temos um especialista temos ter 10 mil
horas de trabalho aqui pessoas
habilitadas para poder dizer que aquilo
que nós ficamos aqui e isso é bom e
próximo a nós com disponibilidade de vir
aí a nossa mira a nossa terra a terra
que também tem uma língua que é comum e
e em nossa no sentido é muito
interessante verificarmos que temos
muitas pessoas com 10 mil lojas trabalho
isso é um ato de amor sai japino sexo
seja mas também é um ato de amor isso
que é grande natureza sexual
pelo menos a minha relação na minha área
com disciplinas que
de alguma forma me apaixonado eu também
tenho um ato de amor ao rio que não
substituem outros físicos não é nomeada
de comer mas de passagem que temos essa
essa relação com o conhecimento o
conhecimento científico porque e aí foi
uma grande taça é o neuton não estou bem
mas fiquei em agradavelmente chocava com
o facto também aí haver uma cultura
científica possível em um país onde nós
somos de um giro da cultura científica
com um
temos aqui um doce capacidade porque
grande parte somos a falar de português
e quer dizer então que há ainda aquela
língua é inglês
nós também temos uma língua global
portuguesa em todo tempo vivemos e
fazemos coisas e de alguma forma o são
paulo se inspirarem ser inspirava por
essa essa situação
já o móvel aprendi tanta coisa e mandar
instituídas tem a cabeça em água e já
nem me lembro vai me acho que minha alma
azul pela chuva
confunde as coisas discutir alguns erros
de português mas a informação era tanta
que esta coisa devia ser feita no
próximo
então eu aqui atentar a galera sabe mas
vi algum móvel de algum modo a mim
parece que é o tema que era de grande
risco porque tu aumente pois temos pouco
de falar nós próprios a expor porque
temos pouco investimento muitas vezes
nós próprios por isso acho eu essa
leitura é e eu penso que aqui ficou vai
provar que somos capazes de se outra
coisa que também ficou provava é que é
possível mobilizar no porto um jogo
fantástico sozinho aí eu acho que o
manuel ea equipe estão de parabéns
eu acho que o primeiro ponto é ter é
mesmo antes de fazermos uma breve
análise escrita uma salva de palmas por
manoel
a hora é agora a acredito não concordo
com um talude cena brinca clã andré mas
é este precisamente um bom espírito que
aqui está é debater as idéias sem ter a
necessidade de uma pessoa por um pé à
frente um pé atrás e ouvir as pessoas
que achou uma foi uma das subidas das
últimas coisas as minhas últimas como
desastre é essa que também ser surdo é
para que o que não é positivo muitas
vezes também são os surdos para que o
que é positivo e isso é complicado
eu estava mesmo me mandaram para que nós
queria ser um desastre que o peso mais
de alguns que o tema botar estudo
observa que a prisão não admitirá mas
aprendi imenso e vão ter que pensar
naquilo que aprendi é e eu senti também
é uma é uma foto de sangue porque eu
estando ligado à área das tecnologias e
dos computadores ea matemática também
como base de creme há muitos anos para
15 anos uma coisa que chamava a
humanização das tecnologias de
informação e andai provavelmente mais de
uma dezena de anos a dizer que a
tecnologia aproxima as pessoas e que era
neutra no sentido que as pessoas que
faziam alguma coisa dela
estamos a ver é e eu já tenho um aspecto
que estes tomem a dizer este tipo de
coisas
há 15 anos a coisa toda a gente dizia
para eu ter uma formação esquisita isto
é família etc enfim e e eu sinto e isso
é importante
mais do que as e esse tipo de abordagem
acho eu é claramente uma mais valia uma
contenção lusitana
nós sentimos temos essa esse filme iria
alguma forma é que um tio sam dia que é
que
existe campo para uma pessoa fazer
coisas existem outras pessoas a fazer
coisas desse tipo também no time
obrigado
[Aplausos]